the jurogan experience i miss training
with dwayne like i
that whole situation with faber
obviously very
very upsetting yeah it is man and i
stayed out of the middle of it
you know i have a ton of respect for
faber and i have a ton of respect for
dwayne as do i so
yeah i love both of those guys it sucked
and you know i talked to dwayne about it
and i talked to faber about him like ah
i know i can't do anything i don't know
them well enough to get in the middle of
it and
arbitrate but i feel like the the
improvement that everybody was making
under dwayne was tangible it was
noticeable yeah it's like he came along
and all of a sudden also
everybody had this footwork they're
moving good their striking combinations
seem to be improving
i agree yeah tj for sure was the most
he benefited the most he took to it
probably the best for sure like a duck
to water
yeah yeah it worked perfect for tj his
style of wrestling
his body style and his ability to
i mean tj is one of those guys that gets
obsessed too and him and dwayne just
really meshed on that
on that fact of notepad writing
you know mapping everything out and
tj has that memory you know that kind of
comes along with it where he can
remember all these different crazy
combos and then get out there and
actually perform it
like yeah that takes a special athlete
to be able to
see that thing on paper train it and
then actually hit it in a fight
the wild thing about his fight with san
hagen was san hagen had him
in a [ __ ] triangle locked up
and i was like man i wonder if
he had some like pointers on how to
finish that better
that would have been it because it
seemed
locked the [ __ ] in i mean he went
through a he threw a knee
right and then uh tj takes him down
and in the process of taking him down he
locks up
fully locked up triangle early in the
fight and i was like man
i feel like he's got this and i was like
i thought tj was going to tap
yeah man i mean that dude's a beast i
was worried for tj going into that fight
i mean that's
a lot of people are like oh i think tj's
gonna go in there and just destroy and
i'm like ah
like i you guys destroyed san hagen i
mean the only guy who's ever really
destroyed him
was um was aldo and all joe
took him down and choked him yeah and al
james got some [ __ ] nasty jujitsu you
know
yeah no i i definitely knew this was
going to be a tough fight and it was a
tough fight coming off of
that long you know and like tj's not
getting a tune-up fight like this is
going to make or break like show
everyone tj's back
or tj's gonna have to fight a couple
times and get back but
it's close to the decision as you're
ever gonna see yeah i mean like you
could
you can make an argument that that san
hagan did more damage
and you can make an argument that uh
dilshah controlled them more yeah i'm a
damaged guy i lean towards damage always
yeah but tj's close-ass [ __ ] fight
it was close ass fight well i i
guarantee they're going to run it back
oh they are going to see that at least
one more time yeah so
well unfortunately with tj's surgery i
mean he has like several
major tears in that knee you really
never know
what a guy's like once you get your knee
mangled like that because
the pain like it might inhibit training
it might become a problem you know it's
so hard to say on tj's post he said it
happened at this part right here
where his knee gets all twisted yeah
heel hook right there that's the heel
hook
yeah yeah so he was yanking on that heel
hook
yeah you could see it i mean go go back
and by the way that is the worst kind of
heel look the inside heel hook right
there
that's so nasty so tj just didn't tap
and he just tore his [ __ ] apart
yeah you can see it there see him
keeping yeah he's keeping his weight off
it there for a second
right here he falls too in the second
round it's just
well i'm sure because his knee was
[ __ ] mangled already and look at him
stepping on it
yeah he's walking i guess i didn't
notice that before but
yeah he he played it off well he really
did a good job playing it off and
and gutting it out because he was
obviously in like some serious pain
yeah right there he got clipped but part
of getting dropped there was because he
had no balance on that left leg it was
very wobbly you know catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost all
for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience